most companies or organizations the
bigger they get
they tend to get less innovative
storytelling is the oldest thing that
humans do
we've been doing it for thousands and
thousands of years
the bigger the company the more problems
i have
so why you are still small company
enjoy it want to be happy live a life
not just a business
i believe hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven best
lessons from elon musk
warren buffett jeff bezos and other
billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one innovate fast enough with elon musk
the real way i think you you actually
achieve intellectual property protection
is by innovating fast enough if your
rate of innovation
is high then you don't need to worry
about protecting vip
because other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure your rate of innovation
is fast
um speed is really speed of innovation
is what is what matters
um and i do i do say this to my teams
like
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go innovation per year if you
what
i say like is is what matters not
innovation
absent time because if you wanted to
take say
um 100 improvement in something and that
took a hundred years
or one year that's radically different
so um it's like what is your rate of
innovation
that that matters and is the rate of
innovation
is that accelerating or decelerating
um and a weird thing happens when
companies get big is that
most companies or organizations the
bigger they get
they tend to get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
is not there for innovation
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation
the incentive structure must be aligned
with that
that's fundamental rule number two learn
from experience with jack ma
we faced a lot of challenges but i'm
sure alibaba is going to face
more challenges we worry every day
when i was young when company was young
we thought well
what if when alibaba become that big
my life would be easier then now the
companies that
the bigger the company the more problems
i have
so why you are still a small company
enjoy it you will never experience
the happiness of operating a small
company
any life we're going to be too big you
have so much headaches
so many things happening and people say
jack you know there are a lot of books
about you
but there's none of the books i write
myself if there's one book i want to
write
in the future it's called alibaba 1001
mistakes
we made so many mistakes
we had so many troubles believing or not
china build up e-commerce company
build up a internet related company
no internet connection at that time
no v no no credit cards
no delivery system it's
so we make we meet problems all the time
it's not easy but we tell ourselves
we will be successful until we make 10
000 mistakes
we will be successful if we survive
in any crisis so when crisis came
we know it's a challenge everybody
start to be united we solve the
challenge
then we complete each other before
we solve the problem of the crisis we
should not complain
so i have a problem in
in hr i have a problem in financing i
have a problem in technology i have a
problem everywhere tell me so that's why
i i become a mentor in
entrepreneurs uh program in china
people a lot of entrepreneurs have
crashing when i listen to their
questions
oh my god i have this problem too so
i would say we have gone through almond
almost nine more than 90 percent of the
problems
that any entrepreneur 90 of the problems
that any entrepreneurs have met this is
what we feel
proud at the end of the day i'm going to
tell my kids my grandchildren
it's not the thing we feel proud we
we made alibaba it's so many mistakes
that we overcome so many challenges
we experience that make me feel proud
life is about experience
so when you become entrepreneur don't
worry about the competitors
don't worry about the mistakes don't
worry about the challenges
go through it that's the great fun part
of your business of your experience and
then
you got a courage you got a wisdom you
got a team follow you
rule number three swing for the fences
with bill gates
i feel like you always seem to swing for
the fences in general it's just sort of
a new way of framing it
but i have to ask if you are swinging
for the fences
what if you miss well hopefully uh
you get more than one swing
either at the same problem like you know
multiple malaria vaccine constructs so
that you know
if you have two or three the combined
chance of success is much higher or
that you're working in multiple areas
not just one area
right you know in climate for example i
have a company that's
uh trying to make a nuclear reactor
that would be very cheap and that would
have safety so that the public
would be very accepting of it now
you know even i realize that's high risk
you know less than 50 percent chance all
that comes together and yet
uh if it did
and the only reason i'm involved is it
would really help with climate
uh let us generate electricity without
any greenhouse gases
rule number four stay grounded with
oprah winfrey
my life is fueled by my being
and the being fuels the doing so i come
from a
centered place i come from a focused
place
i come from compassion
it's just my nature i come from a
willingness to understand
and to be understood and i come from
wanting to
to to connect i mean the secret of that
show
for 25 years is that people could see
themselves in me
all over the world they could see
themselves in me
and even as i became
more and more financially successful
which was a big surprise to me i was
like oh my god this is so
exciting um you mean you got more than
that thirty thousand i got more than
thirty
thousand by the time i was thirty so
so my but what i realized is
through the whole process because i'm
grounded
in my own self
that although i could have more shoes
my feet stayed on the ground although i
was wearing better shoes these are kind
of cute today too
so i could keep my feet on the ground
even though i could get more shoes
and i could understand i could
understand that it really was
because i was grounded i've done the was
doing and continue to this day to do
the consciousness work i work at staying
awake
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series it's free
the link to join is in the description
below it's important to associate with
people that are
better than yourself i remember nine
years ago when i started the alipay
people said jack don't touch the
financing sector because it's illegal
you may be in prison
when you want to do something new you
have to you have to apply
the the physics approach rule number
five care about your product with mark
zuckerberg
i remember distinctly i had this one
friend um
who i i went and got pizza with almost
every night we did all our computer
science problem sets together
at harvard and at the time i remember
talking to him about
how um i was working on this facebook
thing and i thought it would be cool
for harvard and i really was excited
about it because i wanted to use it
but at the same time how i thought that
over time someone would definitely go
build this
version of this for the world but it
wasn't going to be us it was going to be
you know microsoft or you know someone
who
built software for hundreds of millions
of people it's like who we were college
students right we're not
qualified in any way to build this and
you know i think a lot of my takeaway
from that was that
we just kind of cared more than those
other companies about making it exist
rule number six don't follow the numbers
with warren buffett
i look at a lot of figures just in
connection with our businesses i
i uh i like to get numbers so
so i i'm getting reports in weekly in
some businesses
uh uh that but that doesn't tell me what
the economy's gonna do six months from
now or three months from now
it tells me what's going on now with our
businesses
and it really doesn't make any
difference in what i do today
in terms of buying stocks or buying
businesses what those numbers tell me
they're interesting
but they're not they're not guides to me
if if we buy a business we're going to
hold it forever so we're going to have
good years bad years in between years
maybe
a disastrous year or something here and
and
we care a lot about the price we do not
care about the next 12 months
economic predictions just don't enter
into our decisions charlie mugger my
partner i
in you know 54 years now
we've never made a decision based on an
economic prediction
we make business predictions about what
individual businesses will do
over time and we compare that to
what we have to pay for but we have
never said yes
to something because we thought the
economy was going to do well in the next
year or two years and we've never said
no to anything
because we're right in the middle of a
panic even if the price was right
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is be good at storytelling with jeff
bezos
i think this is a golden age of
television so when you look at
you know tv series today the really good
tv series
are in terms of quality they're as good
as the very best
movies have ever been and you now you're
getting the best storytellers
to come to television you're getting the
best actors
to now come do television we're one of
the great storytellers that's right here
thank you for the help
and this is this is a big deal
when when you can get the very best
people because this is
you this is one of those businesses
where
the viewer the the the
is always looking for something a little
fresh
and so you can never find a formula
because as soon as you find a formula
it's not fresh anymore
they're always looking for something a
little new so it really takes human
ingenuity it takes people
the storytellers have to be in touch
with the zeitgeist
and what i want amazon studios to be all
over the world
i want us to be known as the most talent
friendly studio in the world and the
reason you need to do that
thank you
[Music]
is because at the end of the day it is
the talent
that makes those stories storytelling is
the oldest thing that humans do
we've been doing it for thousands and
thousands of years
long before there was written language
before there was any medium to convey it
people sat around
and they told each other stories and
it's how we teach each other things
and we learn from stories we learn from
fiction
we learn from fiction because we get to
live an alternate life
in that moment you watch this and you're
learning it so
it can be fun it can be action it can be
funny it can be comedy
but the very best things take those
elements
and teach a little something there's
something in there that you walk away
with
and you're inspired by it and it doesn't
matter if it's drama
comedy anything you're going to walk
away with something
and there needs to be lightness you know
you can't watch something that's just
all heavy and you're like oh my god you
know i want to kill myself now.
there also has to be that gesture there
has to be somebody who brings you out
and lets you breathe a little bit so
these and this is
so hard to do that's why there is so
much
bad so many bad movies and so many bad
tv shows
because it's in it is one of the hardest
things that humans
do is tell riveting
engaging inspiring stories but when you
get it right
it's a lever that can change the world
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take
action on something you have a 91 chance
of following through
versus just 35 if you got motivated but
never
wrote down a plan and when you share
your plan and have public accountability
it raises your chances of following
through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take
action on it this week let me know put
it down in the comments below what
industry you think still requires a lot
of innovation
all of them seriously i mean
look one of my dad's favorite sayings
was you don't live in the world you were
born into
everything changes all the time
and you know what's better than change
creating change
and so whenever i see something that's
done the way it's always been done
you know like when i got to the mba you
know my whole goal is just to have
things up
right because they everything was done
the exact same way they thought they
were in the business of basketball
for 50 years they thought they were in
the basketball business no you when you
go to a basketball game
you don't remember the jump shots the
dunks you remember who you were with the
fun you had
it's one of the few industries when that
ball is in the air at the end of a game
everybody holds their breath and you're
if it goes in you're hugging people
you've never seen before
you you know so you can take any
industry and look at the way things have
been done
and try to come up and innovate and you
know
and like i said with just the nature of
capitalism right now all the changes
that are required
every industry needs change and there's
a unique opportunity that i don't think
any generation has ever seen
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want to know the
five billion or habits you must copy
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there